I think we approach it a little bit
differently i watch absolutely
everything that I can with the idea that
if there's something good I'll steal it
and then also look out for you know
pitfalls or red flags and the very first
the first things that I rented after
really asked me was was life O'Brien and
then Mel Brooks um history of the world
Moses because they're fantastic very
funny and also you know you have to
watch out for that in because with
anything that has the sort of weight and
potential earnestness of a film like
this you can very easily become funny
unintentionally so I just really wanted
to end any excuse to watch you know
those films is a good excuse and then
and then and then the Torah read the
Torah and read the wonderful book called
Moses of life by Jonathon Kirsch legends
of the Jews and then obviously rich
guidance and Steve Zaillian script and I
tend to avoid watching movies that feel
like they're they're a precursor to a
movie out of fear that I am going to
lean in too much to them but the the
impression of yul brenner was such an
indelible thing for me when I was a
child that there I always had that in
the back of my head I guess so but I
haven't gone back to watch that in the
same way when I I felt terrified doing a
stage production of streetcar I couldn't
bring myself to watch the movie of
streetcar except for the part where my
land was at the bottom of the stairs
yelling Stella because I thought as long
as I can do something different with
that you know over the point of watching
it so that I didn't lean into it you
know so I try and avoid certain things I
like to try and find most of the
research I get first for a character out
of the screenplay and hopefully when
you've got a great project headed by a
great director you know that's been
written by great people there's so much
research that goes into that that you
can just steal that from the script and
then do your own little investigation
see you know how did you manage to say
say Stella differently I whispered it
well whispered it with with true pain
you know some some films it's really
nice to have barely controlled chaos
going on no real idea particularly where
the camera is going to be no idea when
it's gonna be on you just do it and and
and you do a see what happens and sort
of almost you know go start filming
before you're ready and and that works
very nicely for for that film and then
other films where it has it has to be
much more plot driven and so you do need
a bit more definition
you know everything needs everything
needs some sort of an obstacle and
hurdles to define it you know I think
that I've certainly never worked on
anything that has no hurdles and
obstacles at all because then I think
that you know you'd still be work I'd
still be working on it now no one would
ever stop at all with Ridley he's able
to make it in 74 days without
compromising quality I think because
first off he has a team who were really
fantastic who he works with again again
again again again now a lot of directors
do that but then Ridley is very
charmingly impatient right which again
is another nature of directors but he
will work with multiple cameras and
there'd be some scenes not just with
action shots but there might be scenes
in Joel and I would be sitting like this
and there would be six cameras and and
and and I've really enjoyed that because
you didn't ever have to stop to go back
and do oh we've got to get jobs close-up
now now I've got to get my close-up now
we've got to get the double shot you're
getting everything at the same time no
repetition is needed no matching of
takes is ever needed whatsoever you can
just do whatever you want each and every
time it can be very different and and
also he marries this real art
you know he's a painter that's what he
loves to do he sketches non-stop on coal
she gets a stick out puts it in the sand
and sketches to describe to us you know
what he wants
he marries that with it with a real
practical no-nonsense approach to
filmmaking and to having real momentum
you don't sit around much on on Ridley
sets whereas other directors you you can
find yourself sitting around for days
and that doesn't happen were really
Ridley and I were talking about making
the film whilst I was making American
hustle and I walked in the office I was
looking more like a bald Santa Claus
more than Moses and you know and he
looked very shocked and looked like what
the hell has he done here and said no
you got very short hair you know and
tried to avoid looking at my girth and
then you know he must have just been
racing through his brain of okay can I
get somebody else can John T Yates
create a tunic big enough to hide this
and I just tried to lose as much weight
as I could and the tunics were very
helpful and then I continued losing
weight as we as we filmed as well but it
also led us to say well look Moses is
such a fascinating character and and and
both red and I were surprised ourselves
in how complex he was and that he does
he really does go through almost every
human emotion possible and and going far
beyond you know our film you know
we have to find a place to finish at
some point but we we were interested in
keeping on going and making an 8 hour
long film just a I'm not sure anyone
else would have been interested in that
at all but we did we said well are we
really going to get hung up on hair you
know in such a incredible story and
obviously it spans a great deal of time
so hence you know short hair and then
he's got in dreadlocks and he hacks it
and you know sometimes the beard is long
sometimes it's sure and and and and that
and that to me is an example of you know
these hurdles which actually helped to
define a film and and and in the end
enhance it has it created either more of
a spiritual identity or more of a
political consciousness being part of
this I mean I think inevitably that
politics is within the world that we're
showing absolutely an important role and
mixed in with religion but also the the
thing that was very fascinating to me in
in the Torah was the nature of Moses
relationship with God and like he's
described in the film you know that the
definition of Israel Israel is he who
wrestles with God and and Moses did that
non-stop you know he didn't want the job
he initially said no again and again and
again God got quite mad at him there's
actually a passage where God tries to
kill Moses Mizzy pora
saves him by circumcising one of their
sons and and there's that there's that
turmoil throughout and ultimately ending
tragically with Moses not making it to
the promised land to to Canaan and and
so it is it is a story of revolution and
conflict my takeaway if you call it that
from this movie because I was right I
was raised Catholic and this story to me
when I was a child was more of a fable
you know all I saw when I read stories
of the Bible was the animals two by two
and the parting of the Reds
I was mystified by it by those stuff and
I had a young the beginnings of a young
scientific mind and I would always but
how was that possible and oh well if God
made that happen and then I started
having this relationship with God which
was very much guilt driven when my
parents who were only 35 at the time
were just young kids really trying to
raise two boys and and were obviously
tired or you know they've been up too
late on a Saturday so Sunday morning and
two young eager kind of you know
church-going boys who they had created
by sending us in our Holy Communion
let's go to church not this morning so
after a few missing weeks of going to
church I was terrified of going back to
this little wooden house where God was
and and so my relationship with religion
was that coming to this movie what I see
is the reason why those stories are
there what it's there to teach us and
yes you're saying it's the story of a
struggle and a struggle for freedom and
in the inverse of that really is that
you know my characters there to
represent the opposite ethical point of
view that we should have as either a
human or as the leader of other humans
is that one culture should respect
another culture that one person should
respect another person and that we time
and time again don't and that's why this
story is so resonant so the real take
away from me is not so much about
increasing my faith but increasing my
opinion of religion as something that
should be there for the powers of good
and unfortunately so many times that
those ideas and beliefs butting up
against each other cause too much damage